you mentioned your boyfriend Aaron
Rodgers Green Bay Packers and he just
had one of the great quarterbacks he
just had a very tough loss and he is
very likely to win the MVP again he he's
an incredible athlete
it was exciting for me to get to to say
hi to him backstage he didn't seem so no
he's journaling right now about it oh
sure yeah I saw him writing in a big
pink diary but you didn't he's that he's
extremely famous athlete very well-known
but when you met him you didn't know who
he was no I had no idea when I met him I
um I said so so what do you do and he's
like oh I play football what college
he's like oh no I play professional I go
cool what what position he's like
quarterback cool that's so that was that
was kind of it not knowing that he's
like you know Super Bowl MVP or any of
those things
yes all I saw was that he was like
really attractive I didn't really care
what he did but you are such a big man I
thought you're gonna say all I saw was
his good heart and isn't you're like all
I saw he was so hot to the heart yet I'm
still admiring him
alright this means if you're going out
with him would you have been if you're
spending a lot of time in Green Bay yeah
what is that like for you are you
adapting to life in Green Bay yeah I
love it in Green Bay
it's really comfortable there and
everybody's so great there I did realize
when I've gotten really comfortable
there because I had a call with my
representatives and they said you know
can you do this call at four o'clock
like a business calling a business call
can you can we get you on the phone at
four and go oh no I've got meet on hold
and I've got to go pick it up I know
you've got meet on hold yeah I Maplewood
meat market they got to meet on hold and
I got to pick it up they closed and I
gotta go get it and they're like you're
in Green Bay like yes I am so wait so
that's something they probably don't
understand in Los Angeles Midwest thing
it's yes it isn't me on hold
yeah what else what are some any
do you know I put me down hold out here
sure strange do you call a butcher you
need something special you know you put
me on hold
yeah Conan is turning on me all of a
sudden all right to me that just means
you're keeping it in your garage that's
what I do
I've got a lot of cold cuts in my garage
well you can keep them in your fridge
probably takes up space but I love Green
Bay it's everybody's been so wonderful
and it's a home for me now what about
the weather it gets incredibly cold
there you're you grew up in Boston I
grew up in Boston so I can way too much
here you know no I'd be cool I'd be okay
with it I'd be fine with it cuz I grew
up in Boston I spent years in New York
so I'd be okay with it but some people
probably go to a Green Bay and would say
I can't handle this everybody a lot of
people bring that up to me but it's
mostly men and I just think that they
are such [ __ ] when they bring it up
to me really I just think that you're
like cold really like isn't it really
cold aren't you too cold they're like do
you not have a jacket you know you can
push a button in your car a lot of cars
they couldn't you know the seats warm up
so it's it's pretty you know it's pretty
doable I have that button on my car I
never use it but when my wife drives my
cars she uses it and then I know that
she's driven my car cuz I get in it and
I'm driving for a while and suddenly I
smell like ham cooking that's
interesting to know that you would smell
like ham if we cooked you up yes yeah
yeah you smell like I have never cooked
me
Andie's meet on hold right now we're
saving Andy
you